okay guys the story I want to talk about
today has all the ingredients of a
classic eSports scandal it's been going
on for months there are thousands of
words of TWiT longers being exchanged
between both parties there are
allegations of contractual breaches
accusations of unpaid money and even
slander there's just one teensy little
difference between this don't at me and
one we typically do and that's that this
eSports scandal is over sixty eight
dollars and 33 cents USD
[Music]
alright so about a week ago I got a tip
in my DMS about an Australian Rainbow
six siege player who might be owed some
money by his former org okay so I'm on
the case when I see stuff like this I
usually investigate sometimes it turns
out to be a pretty big deal like the
other week when I reported on the
low-key eSports scandal which is an org
that owes globally its players and staff
over 137 thousand dollars this one was
not one of those times this disagreement
was over a grand total of a hundred
Australian dollars Bret but I didn't
drop it for some reason I decided to dig
further into it I don't know I'm just
sickly fascinated by the idea of a very
public eSports dispute over what equates
to sixty eight dollars and 33 cents USD
now stay with me here if you're looking
for some big expose on some of the shady
[ __ ] still goes on in eSports we still
do that but I wanted to take you on this
journey with me because as much as the
$68 thing is ridiculous from the outset
this is actually a pretty interesting
story I talked about the player and the
organ vault and for this story I got to
take you to the mysterious world of
Australian Rainbow six siege it's a
quiet yeah mm-hmm it all started in
December of 2019
when a guy called Todd Francis that's
this guy dropped an eSports classic a
twit longer announcing the circumstances
of his departure from an org called
oddity in sports for a little background
oddity esports was founded in 2018 and
since then they've been in and out of
paladin's Rainbow six siege mortal
kombat and apparently crunk er now the
r16 we're talking about here competed
and pro league down there and they
actually came in third in the Asia
Pacific Australia and New Zealand region
in season 10 now that particular win
netted the team a cool 2500 bucks which
you will note is about 36 times more
money than what this entire dispute is
about anyways apparently some drama on
the team goes down they all decide to
kick a dude named Vinny and Todd is
having none of it
Todd's like I don't like the way you
handle this mm now at this point the
roster lock for that region has either
already happened or it's about - so Todd
willingly rides out the next little
while without an active roster to
participate in Todd and Oddity start to
negotiate the terms for mutual
termination of his contract in the midst
of this Todd sends Oddity an invoice for
a hundred Australian dollars see under
the terms of his contract
Todd is entitled to get reimbursed for
$50.00 per week for food and expenses
incurred at LAN events while
participating as a member of the team
fine so he claims two weeks for two
events the Melbourne eSports open and
Ubisoft XP now here's where things start
to go sideways oddity hits him back
after he sends that invoice and just
says no they say two problems Todd
number one you only have receipts for
one event so that's 50 bucks not a
hundred number two you're in breach of
your contract because you didn't tweet
three times about our sponsors like we
told you - yes part of this dispute
involves Todd's refusal to tweet three
times in one month about Oddity sponsors
according to a 2,500 word statement
released by oddity on the matter
Todd agree
to do the three tweets to fulfill his
contractual obligations and then back
though it's at this point that I would
like to read you my personal favorite
paragraph from this very very long
statement pod quote believed if we were
to hold the player in question to the
three social posts as discussed that the
organization would be quote bucking me
over the player then informed us that
should we want to [ __ ] anyone over
we should quote [ __ ] over the people who
caused this situation obviously we had
and have no intention of [ __ ] anyone
over and we're looking to provide the
best outcomes for players the teams as a
whole and the organization and quote
that actually made me laugh out loud the
first time I read it not because I doubt
the truthfulness of that statement just
the way they wrote it now I asked Todd
why didn't you do those two retweets and
he basically told me that he didn't
think he was gonna get the hundred bucks
whether he did or didn't do the three
tweets so he just did it for what
exactly he had to tweet about well it
would be either beef jerky peripherals
or gaming chairs honestly all great
things why can't we be sponsored by beef
jerky okay forget about the tweets for a
second though what about those missing
receipts from the second event that
would net him that second 50 Australian
dollars well Todd says that yeah he
doesn't have the receipt but he has bank
statements that prove he bought the food
ah now it's worth noting here that I
have seen the contract I've read the
part about reimbursement and technically
it does say that repayment is due when
the org gets the requisite receipts not
necessarily a bank statement during this
whole thing there were three twit
longers dropped between Todd and Oddity
and honestly some pretty questionable
tweets by both parties if I'm being
totally honest but wait see Todd had
dinner at one of those events with a
co-owner of oddity the co-owner paid the
whole bill for the dinner and later
asked Todd to pay his share which he did
now Todd says he wants that money back
because if he has to provide a receipt
to oddity that oddity has to provide a
receipt to him look
Todd's claim is not backed up by any
tract but you do have to wonder if
you're an eSports org owner even if your
org is really small and you take a
player out for dinner and you pay for it
are you really gonna ask for that money
back I mean like what if my boss the CEO
of the score was like yo Colin I'm gonna
take you to Red Lobster don't you worry
about it you can PayPal me afterwards
yeah kind of a weird move he take it
holds the Red Lobster's then movies okay
so where does this all leave us well
Todd quit oddity eSports then he
invoiced them for a hundred bucks oddity
is like no dice buddy you don't have the
right receipts plus you didn't fulfill
your contractual obligations go tweet
about beef jerky but there is a
compromise here one of the co-owners of
Oddity told me that because Todd does
have the correct receipts for one of the
events they will pay him fifty
Australian dollars that's 34 bucks us
for that event if he amends his invoice
to be 50 bucks not 100 now in all
seriousness we might be having a little
bit of fun at the expense of this
situation which involves basically
inconsequential money but it is a really
fascinating case study in what happens
in small orgs in small scenes when the
relationship between a player and the
team totally breaks down this time it's
over 68 bucks us another time in another
situation it could be overall a lot more
now when it comes to this particular
case I can sympathize with both sides
Todd really believes he is owed that 100
Australian dollars and he has some kind
of proved towards it I can respect that
out of the eSports for their part truly
believe he is owed at maximum half of
that because he was only able to prove
half of what he's claiming and he failed
to live up to his supposed contractual
obligations with their sponsors and I
can respect that
from what both parties have told me I
don't actually think anyone's gonna
pursue legal action here and I don't
know if Todd is gonna take the 50 bucks
compromise
whatever happens with this you got to
think in a small insular scene like
Rainbow six siege Australian eSports
this very public spat has to be damaging
for both parties guys one final note
after the video proper has ended I do
get a lot of my stories these days from
helpful tips that low-key thing was a
tip and it turned out to be huge this
funny little story was a tip and it
turned out to be fascinating if you've
got something that you'd like the don't
happy team to investigate that's not
just me that's Devin that's Keith that's
Dan Rosen well you can hit us up at tips
at the score com
how about that also my DMS are always
open